morning. Plan today
is quick hour and a half session right
now. Okay, that was weird. Internet just
flipped for some reason. That might just
be reream switching servers. Uh anyways,
the goal for
today, get the sweeps code into a
reasonable
place. Clean up all the comments in the
protein
algorithm. Probably clean up all the new
configs since we made big changes to the
way configuration works. Fix
that. And uh yeah, then we will go from
there. I think there's still stuff that
we want to do with the main script and
the way that everything is launched.
Uh but also we want to be like we want
to get to this place where we can start
running final or close to final
experiments as soon as
possible. That would be ideal. Um but
the closer to the final version of the
code we get before we do that the
better. Uh, I also know that there's
going to be probably multiple days of
annoying packaging to do for this
release because we have to ship CUDA
kernels, which means we have to ship
binaries. Uh, and the process of
building those is not fun. Unless I find
some clever way around that, we're just
going to have to figure that
out. Let's get started
here. We're going to start
on
protein. First of all, let me make sure
that we have a
is our sweep file. It's
currently a lot longer than I remember
it. We have this data here for
hyperparam testing.
So, this I actually think we're going to
keep because we're going to want this
for like
initial experiments. We might even want
to clean it up. I think I want to go
through all these comments and see if
any of these look like applicable
stuff. So, what's this? Less than num
samples. We do a random
sample. Yeah. So what I did instead is
the first one is the best set of
hyperparames that you currently
have. We can basically start it from
saying defaults.
I wonder how that's actually going to
work
[Music]
with. You know, it's a little bit odd
actually because like this is going to
make it hard to compare
now we only use this uh we use it by
default but we have an option to not use
it. What's this? Clip random samples to
bound so we don't get high bad cost
samples. Yeah, there's no clipping on
these. But all the any changes to the
core algorithm are going to require
quite extensive experiments to resolve.
Um, it actually might make sense to
start
drafting the
article while I'm doing this because or
at least make some notes for the
article because we are going to write
like a
big a big blog post on this.
I think it's going to be 2.5. We might
make it 300 if it's really good, but I
think more likely this is a 2.5.
I should put this not in front of the
chat. So the original goal with
protein was to eliminate edge
stops exploring when you have perfect
model
of it. But also it doesn't actually give
you it doesn't actually run experiments.
So protein uh protein should actually
run
experiments along the
entire
frontier much
simpler as well.
Now I what we want to do is like protein
other stuff
tried because I tried like a dozens of
different things.
So dozens of different scoring
normalization objective functions tested
during
development. A few things we
tried to like
One of the big things I think that was
like one of the really difficult things
was like
um how we get it to explore
uh score like percentile
scores. I'm trying to remember what we
ended up doing for this.
Let me look at the current algorithm and
like refresh my memory a little bit on
what we did here.
So the y value which is your score
variable just gets
normalized. Then you train GP score on
that. You
train linearly normed um log cost
function and then you have this norm on
here. You so you
unnorm the
predictions just used for logging. Okay.
Hey, welcome
boxing. Um, we're looking at we're
starting to actually go through all the
different components now, make some
notes, and clean up the final
code. Twitter stream is down. Damn it.
How do I fix that? It just didn't go
back up when
I All right, you know what? Let me just
let me just start stop and start the
whole thing. is ridiculous.